- [Narrator] Why Ronald Reagan's
presidency so significant?
- Ronald Reagan plays an important role in
the modern presidency for
two big things that he did.
One on the domestic front,
he broke considerably with
the kind of way of doing
things in Washington.
He basically in response to the New Deal,
Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
and the Great Society from Lyndon Johnson,
President Reagan came in and said
no longer is government your
friend in American life.
The government is actually the problem.
This is the message of
his inaugural address.
And he broke with the idea
that the federal government
through the application of its resources,
could help American life,
which was a very stark ideological break
with the way the American
government had been going
since the mid 40s.
And then on foreign policy,
his increased defense spending
and his very strong position
against the Soviet Union
coupled with a willingness
to actually negotiate
with the Soviet Union,
which got him a lot of grief
from conservatives in his party,
that both hard line and
ability to negotiate
helped usher in the end of the Cold War.